le vieux-québec et meurtri la douleur
est encore vive des mémoriaux improvisé
voit le jour dans le quartier et les
gens pleurent les disparus pierre
paquette prends ça marche ici tous les
matins c'est l'endroit où françois
duchesne a été assassiné c'est mon vieux
québec qui aimant québec mais elle est à
toi cette cape il s'est depuis
l'événement c'est en ça repose en paix
va vers la lumière sur la rue des
remparts ou suzanne clairement a elle
aussi été tué les résidents tente de se
consoler me promène au plus choyés
france aso chez vue c'est très violent
s'est suicidé c'est gratuit ça compte
pas de bon sens de chaleur qui ont eu
des coups d'épée c'est tout le quartier
qui est encore sous le choc
le propriétaire de la boutique de noël
n'en revient toujours pas des proches de
son employé se sont retrouvées sur le
chemin du suspect et deux de ses amis se
sont fait blesser ici exactement au chu
somme trottoir s'il n'y a plus de
marcheurs et de curieux à l'intérieur
des murs du vieux québec les policiers
eux sont là pour tenter de rassurer les
gens qu'est-ce qu'on veut dire à la
population c'est le plus vite possible
je crois faudrait reprendre une vie
normale
on est conscient que le sentiment de
sécurité d'histoire n'y est peut-être et
bras les présentes mais étant donné les
événements qu'on a vécu samedi le réseau
de la santé de la capitale-nationale
déploie des ressources psychosocial près
des lieux du drame
il ya des gens qui peuvent se sentir
présente sur très stressée très inquiets
des problèmes de sommeil par exemple
peut avoir des niveaux ce2 des primes
possible il ya des gens qui sont en état
post traumatique ou ceux ci ont vu
directement les
les situations sont entendus des
chambres des intervenants du ciu ce
désir aussi les écoles du quartier
les parents encore ébranlé ont dû tenter
de trouver les mots justes ce matin j'en
parle encore ce matin avec ma fille dans
la voiture piégée expliquer un peu
commun où ça s'était passé au city pour
puis c'est sûr que même pour nous de
revenir ici ce matin ils ont leur parler
du sujet en fait de façon 100 mètres
trop de détails
parce qu'on trouve que c'est important
de repenser de partager cette
information là parce que nous et tout le
monde va s'empaler dans l'école les
heures passent mais la douleur est
toujours aussi vive
on espère que les temps vont faire
disparaître un peu cette douleur suite à
ce drame le coeur de la capitale
nationale aura besoin de temps pour
guérir
alors que tous sont toujours plongé dans
l'incompréhension ici pierre alexandre
bolduc radio canada québec